good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that great thing that you have
inside you explode out into the world
and have a big impact so to help you in
your journey today's message is you
become what you believe over to you
Oprah Winfrey create the highest
grandest vision possible for your life
because you become what you believe when
I was a little girl
Mississippi growing up on the farm only
Bukka weed is a role model watching my
grandmother boil clothes and a big iron
pot through the screen door because we
didn't have a washing machine and made
everything we had
I watched her and realized somehow
inside myself and the spirit of myself
that although this was segregated
Mississippi and I was colored and female
that my life could be bigger greater
than what I saw I remember being 4 or 5
years old I certainly couldn't
articulate it but it was a feeling and a
feeling that I allowed myself to follow
I allowed myself to follow because if
you were to ask me what is the secret to
my success it is because I understand
that there is a Power greater than
myself that rules my life and in life in
life if you can be still long enough in
all of your endeavors the good times the
hard times to connect yourself to the
source I call it God you can call it
whatever you want to the force nature
Allah the power if you can connect
yourself to the source and allow the
energy that it is your personality your
lifeforce to be connected to the greater
force in the thing is possible for you I
am proof of that I think that my life
the fact that I was
born where was born in the time that I
was and have been able to do what I've
done
speaks to the possibility not that I am
special but that it could be done if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details